in this video we're going to talk about
how to find the inverse of a function
algebraically and we're going to do a
little bit more challenging example so
if you want to try this problem on your
own go ahead and pause the video and see
if you can do it and then we'll go
through it now remember when you find
the inverse of function algebraically
what you want to do is you want to
switch the X and Y variables and you
want to solve for that new y variable so
in this problem what we're going to do
is we're going to replace f of x with y
and I'm just going to bring the rest of
this function here down but now what
we're going to do is where we see X
we're going to put Y and vice versa so X
is equal to 5y minus 3 all divided by 3y
plus one and now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to clear this fraction by
multiplying both sides by the
denominator 3y Plus 1.
foreign
together so now you can see these are
going to cancel one another out and if
we distribute this x into the
parentheses here we're going to get 3 X
Y plus X is equal to 5y minus 3. now
here's where students get a little bit
tripped up in the sense that there's a y
here and there's a y here so how are we
going to get that y by itself right so
what we need to do is get everything
that has that variable that we want on
one side everything else on the other so
what I'm going to do here is I'm going
to subtract the 5y
from both sides
and so that's going to give us
3 X Y minus 5y plus X is equal to
negative 3 and I'm going to move this x
to The Other Side by subtracting X from
both sides
and if I do that that's going to give us
let's put the answer up here it's going
to give us 3xy
minus 5y
is equal to negative 3 minus X or we
could say negative x minus 3. okay so
now what we want to do is we want to
factor out that that y so I'm going to
pull the Y out or divide it out or
factor it out and that's going to leave
us with 3x minus 5. you can check your
work to see if you did it right by
Distributing that y back into the
parentheses and then now all we have to
do is divide by this quantity here 3x
minus 5.
to get this y by itself whatever we do
to the left we want to do to the right
keep it balanced and so now you can see
we have y is equal to negative x minus 3
all over 3x minus 5. instead of writing
it y we can use the inverse notation F
inverse of X that's what that minus 1
represents and we've got our final
result
now if you want to see some more
examples where I talk about finding the
inverse of a function algebraically I'll
put a video right there follow me over
to that video and we'll do some more
examples